حمله تصحيح الخطا كما وصفها بوتين لم تخلو
من الاخطاء هي الاخرى فما نجا منه في
القرن عام 2014 وقع فيه في اوكرانيا
على مدار العام المنقضي تقدمت القوات
الروسيه على اكثر من جبهه لكنها سرعان ما
كانت تفقد ما تكسبه لتثار التساؤلات عما
اذا كانت اخطاء بوتين تكتيكيه ام منهجيه
انقسم الخبراء حول تفسير ما حدث فقسم منهم
ذهب لتكرار الاخطاء اللوجستيه للقوات
الروسيه بينما ذهب قسم اخر لسوء قراءه
بوتين نفسه للتاريخ الذي دفعه لاطلاق هذه
العمليه فبوتين اطلق حملته على مبدا انه
يقاتل من اجل امن روسيا ضد توسع الناتو
وان قاده الحلف يحاولون تقسيم روسيا كما
فعلوا مع الاتحاد السوفيتي عام 1991
لكن تحت هذا العنوان العريض عناوين فرعيه
اخرى رسمت خط الرجل ولم يطمسها غبار الوقت
رغم مرور اكثر من عقدين على حدوثها يعود
اولها لعام 1990 يرى ان الناتو اخلف وعده
بعدم التوسع شرقا بعد ان سمحت موسكو
بتوحيد المانيا وتنازلت عما كانت تراه حقا
لها في ذلك الوقت اما الحدث الثاني فغير
بعيد اذ يرى بوتين حنفا جديدا بالوعد الذي
قطعه النيتو على نفسه في ميثاق التاسيس
الصادر في السبع والعشرين من مايو عام
1997 فيما الحدث الثالث يراه بوتين على
انه كان لحظه ظهور الناتو على حقيقته
عندما قصف صربيا في نزاع كوسوفو عام
واخيرا القشه التي قسمت ظهر البعير في قمه
بوخارست عام 2008 والتي رحب فيها الناتو
بتطلعات اوكرانيا و جورجيا للانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو
اذا اعتمد بوتين على كل هذه الحسابات او
الهواجس وانطلق لكن خبراء يرون انه رغم
خوفه من الناتو فقد اساء تقدير قوته وسرعه
الدعم الذي قد يقدمه لاوكرانيا فضلا عن
انه اساء اصلا تقدير قوه الاوكرانيين
ورغبتهم في الدفاع عن ارضه